[Applause]
Matt Damon's kiddos make a rare public
appearance at the premiere of their
dad's new flick Heir if we're together
we're good on Monday the Oscar winner
posed with his wife of 17 years Luciana
barroso and their three daughters 16
year old Isabella 14 year old Gia and 12
year old Stella the fam rocked matching
outfits Matt and Luciana in head to toe
black the kids in florals of course the
girls were there to support their famous
dad whose new flick tells the story of
Nike exec Sonny Vaccaro pursuing Michael
Jordan for a shoe deal when he was just
a rookie in the NBA my name is Sonny
Vaccaro I'm with Nike do you typically
make it a habit of showing up at
people's front doors unannounced I don't
like to take no for an answer oh man
here we go Matt's longtime bestie Ben
Affleck also stars in the movie and
directed it 25 years after they won an
Oscar for Goodwill Hunting we never
would have thought really that it was
possible I mean because we never thought
that anyone would buy it or that it
would actually go through the Hollywood
sort of channels much less you know
end up winning Academy Awards I think
maybe I'll get up there and I'll knock
on the door and you won't be there
no goodbye and I'll see you later no
nothing
just left
I don't know much but I know that what
is the magic between you and Ben I think
it mostly comes from me I would say no
uh we grew up together uh we see the
world in a really similar way it makes
working together really easy there's an
underlying respect so it's like you can
get to the solution a lot quicker
because you're like dude that sucks you
know what I mean this is actually where
we premiered Goodwill Hunting like right
here yeah that's theater where we're
gonna go yeah yes you want to see it in
the same theater where you're in the
same theater and now I have my kids with
me it's just crazy it's just nuts man
it's what a life
ET also spoke to Ben on Monday who
opened up about Matt's physical
transformation to play sunny I find you
players and I feel it this time don't
change that now yes who's never set foot
on an NBA court if that's the literal
definition of rookie yeah I wanted to
put Matt in a bodysuit put some weight
on him and we shot him with the lens
that expanded his face a little bit to
make him look a little bit I know it
sounds like like it was not like a goofy
like you know Instagram you know filter
prank thing but it was I felt like you
know audience are so accustomed to
seeing Matt Damon as the kind of Jason
Bourne can't lose gonna win no matter
what and I wanted to try to create more
of that sort of Underdog feeling you
know I need the greatest basketball
shoot that's ever been made who's to
play
Michael Jordan the also Stars Chris
Tucker Jason Bateman and Viola Davis who
Jordan's mom
a shoe is just
while the NBA star wasn't directly
involved with the project he met with
Ben prior to filming and gave it his
Blessing casting Biola was his idea how
did it feel when you heard Michael
Jordan wanted you to play his mama
[Music]
terrifying seeing his mama speaking to
his mama that is a formidable woman that
woman is Zen neutrality solid
so I said you know obviously you see
something in me that reminds you of your
mother so I feel flattered by that so
let me step into this role scared but I
stepped into it
[Music]